[Music]
[Applause]
he is rick stroud and he covers the
tampa bay buccaneers for the tampa bay
times and he joins us on the program
what the hell happened last night rick
i don't know but i think it means you're
gonna win the super bowl cause the last
two times they did that they got swept
by the saints in the regular season so
you know nothing's changed
but is this how big is is this locally
because nationally it feels like all
right just like a
aberration all right so they had a bad
night here they don't do well against
the saints
does the sky fall in tampa when
something like this happens
i think it does from this standpoint i
mean they lost their top two receivers
right and they're leading running back
so that is not a small thing i mean
chris godwin has a sprained mcl he's not
coming back any time soon some of these
guys might be out until the postseason
um you know and now you know the seating
is they're not gonna get the number one
seat so if they make it to the
championship game they're gonna have to
pack the thermals go back to green bay
and do all that over again this was a
pretty seismic loss to a team that has
owned them i mean brady's own four uh in
the regular season since he's been here
with the bucks and they've got the
formula on defense to take down this
tampa bay team
antonio brown is coming back
why
well so much for the last strike rule
right that is because the umpire is tom
brady right i mean bruce arian said one
more so it doesn't matter and what
better time to get a receiver back than
when you've lost your top two guys they
said they would do what's best for the
football team and that means antonio
brown because they're down to him and
brachard perriman who was off uh with
the covid he's the guy that was
the game-winning touchdown in overtime
you know against the bill so really
those are their top two receivers right
now the other guys didn't do anything
and gronk had maybe one of the worst
games i've seen him play i mean he had
11 targets just two cats he's dropped a
ton of footballs so they're desperate
right now for some guys that can catch
the ball for tom brady what's new
orleans do
that very few teams if any other teams
can do to tom brady
well what they're able to do is lock
down their outside receivers in man
coverage they play really good tight man
coverage marshawn lattimore has had a a
running battle for years with mike evans
he does a really good job so it's a lot
of combat catches a lot of close tight
throws they're able to rush four guys
and and impact the quarterback you know
cam jordan had an unbelievable day he
seems to do that every time they play
mario davis and kwon alexander are very
active they can blitz them on third down
and then they can play cover two with
the two high safety so you don't get
anything over the top so it's really the
perfect plan
against the bucks and and you know they
they were not executing very well to say
the least
you know you got guys who are sore
losers but they say they're ultra
competitive you know urban meyer brought
this up in his interview with ian
rappaport you know tom brady is not a
gracious loser
[Music]
anybody have a problem with that
well only probably not because he's such
a terrific winner i mean he's won more
than anybody but you're right i mean
barking at dennis allen on the sidelines
uh i think he you know he had
intentional grounding on a surface on on
his own bench and threw one of those
down
he is not a guy you want to be around
when he loses games
he has said this before that you know
winning to him now at this stage with
the expectations is more of a relief
than it is much of a joy and losing it
just eats at him alive and i don't want
to put him in the urban meyer category i
mean he doesn't walk around like that um
he'll get over it pretty well and he'll
focus on the next game but he's
miserable when he loses because he's
just not used to doing it we had bruce
arians on last week and he said that
this year was supposed to be the super
bowl year not last year do you think he
still feels that way
well i think he's glad he won one uh you
know because it worked out for him and
they wouldn't have gone on the road this
year and you know played in front of
half empty stadiums i mean it worked out
for them that they were the road team
and did that
um you know they brought back the 22
starters but
every year is different dan they were
lucky with injuries they've been
decimated in the secondary with it this
year now you've lost a couple of
receivers on offense where they've been
pretty healthy all year
so this is why it's so hard to repeat
you know it's just hard to win one much
less two doesn't matter who your
quarterback is but they're not out of
this thing they'll have a say
in the postseason they need to win one
more game they got the panthers twice
and the jets in between them they're
going to win the nfc south i believe and
then they got to hope that they get a
home game or two and uh will have to go
on the road and win a championship
if i said you had to bet on one the
buccaneers win the super bowl or the
buccaneers lose their first playoff game
well i mean it's so hard to win a super
bowl i would say the first playoff game
and the way it's trending right now you
know you may see the new orleans saints
back in tampa bay you just don't know
you know they're not out of it either so
depending on the match-up um before this
game it would have been the washington
football team they've struggled against
tyler heideke they lost to him uh up
there in the regular season they didn't
play well in the postseason against them
so
anything can happen when you get in
these these tournaments but brady's been
pretty good uh after winning super bowls
he's gotten back to a few of them he's
he's you know gotten to the championship
game almost every time when he's
defended one of these so uh i think
they'll do well in the playoffs but yeah
just to say they're going to go
back-to-back that hasn't happened since
tom did it so i would definitely take
the the losing in the first round
talking to rick stroud he covers the box
for the tampa bay times he broke the
antonio brown story was that a month ago
um how did you hear about it or what did
you hear at the time about antonio brown
and his vaccination card
well you know antonio brown has a habit
of not paying people uh that he owes and
uh that's sort of how it came to us you
know uh there there was a chef in los
angeles uh he had been part of antonio's
entourage he was more than his chef he
invited him to live in tampa
uh you know he trusted him with his
girlfriend his car and his house key and
i wouldn't do that with anybody but um
you know when he didn't pay him uh he
tried to collect he was unsuccessful but
he had a story to tell and the story was
that you know antonio brown had been
seeking and attained a fake vaccination
card turned out it was actually three
players including john franklin who's a
free agent and we know mike edwards was
involved in that um the bucks didn't
really want to hear about it uh you know
these cards are hard to verify but they
were all from a county that's 80 miles
north of tampa they couldn't get their
story straight down or they would have
gotten away with it um you know antonio
said he went up there by himself he
didn't or he did go by himself and the
other guys you know would have gone on
the same day that didn't make any sense
so they took their punishment they took
the three games rather than make it a
longer suspension and now they're going
to be back and they desperately need
them but it was just a you know
i mean antonio brown has has a history
of doing what's in antonio brown's best
interest he did not keep the team safe
he got covert in week two that's the
thing i think people forget that he was
actually infected with this virus and
could have gotten somebody very sick
including uh you know 69 year old bruce
arians or an 80-something year old tom
moore so it was not a good thing
if tampa won last night and didn't have
injuries to their wide receivers
would antonio brown be on the roster
today
i think he would i think they made that
decision and dan is this simple i don't
know how else to say this what tom brady
wants he is going to get so long as he's
here if tom brady wants antonio brown on
the roster i'm not sure what he would do
short of a suspension that would keep
him off of it they owe tom brady right
he put a trophy in their case almost
tossed it in the river but he gave these
guys uh increases in their salaries um
you know contract extensions they're
indebted to him the ownership loves them
and you know look he's brought in
gronkowski fournette antonio brown those
are his guys and they're the ones that
helped them win a super bowl last year i
think they all cut touchdown passes or
scored one so uh tom brady's running the
show here make no mistake about it
always great to talk to you rick thank
you great work on the antonio brown
story as well
thanks dad that's rick stroud covers the
box for the tampa bay times